for
when thinking about the prophet Sall alam's identity as a servant Prophet as a servant messenger
we want to think and consider what is the most identifiable governing Spirit of that identity
of being a servant prophet and we find that in s Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam Mercy
when he talks about himself he talks about himself as being Mercy as being compassion sallallahu
alaihi wasallam and when Allah tells us and he tells the prophet wasallam essentially about his
governing reality on this life he
says we have not sent you but as mercy and as compassion for all of creation
here means everything of other than Allah and so the mercy of the messenger Muhammad sallallah
alaihi wasallam is that fundamental identifier of what it means to be a servant so that
means that for you and I if I think about my identity as a servant I
have to hear Allah telling me y Muhammad
fatim I have sent you to the world around you as mercy and compassion and the
prophet wasam was told by Allah
and it is because of the mercy that Allah has bestowed upon you you are gentle
and kind to
them if you were harsh and hard-hearted they would have fled from you how often brothers
and sisters do we experience a harshness in our lives harshness with our families harshness with
our loved ones harshness at work at school it's coming from a lack of Spirited
mercifulness that Allah subhana T wants to be at the essence of our servanthood Allah subh
tells us about the
prophet that verily in the messenger Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam you have this messenger that has
come to you from
yourselves that it's very heavy for him to see you and I and Humanity go through
hardship it's hard for him Sall alai
wasallam he's very worried and concerned about us and with the believing men and women gentle
and compassionate so you see that the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam his Spirit of servanthood
meant that he was deeply
caring his mercifulness meant that his compassion exuded all the time for all when thinking about
his duty as a messenger of God and that his Keen concern on seeing people being
well guided Allah tells us in the
Quran it's almost as if you are going to kill yourself in grief because of how
much you seek guidance for others the prophet sallallah alaihi wasallam he experienced a deep visceral
care for The Human Condition he really wanted guidance and wants guidance for all and that
is the spirit of the servant Prophet it's that Mercy I have mercy and compassion that
governs every single day it's a tender awareness of those around me I want people to
be in the best of
States not just in their physical well-being or in their emotional well-being but most critically in
their spiritual theological well-being and you have to ask yourself how often do I really care
about the guidance of others how often do I really care about people's love for Allah
and the love of the messenger Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam is that a concern that I
have for myself spouse is that a governing concern that I really have for my children
that I'm really concerned I really want my sister my brother my father my mother my
aunt my uncle my cousins my friends my community members my neighbors my classmates do I
have that governing
concern of someone who sent as Mercy to all of creation am I disposed as a
servant who's driven by that Spirit that's a question that you have to ask because often
if I don't have that disposition if I'm thinking about myself if I'm thinking about my
career that my the governing ideas of my day are my welfare my happiness my proverbial
purpose in life if that's the governing idea of my day-to-day
reality then there is no mercy there is no compassion there is no love there is
no beauty that exudes it just doesn't happen it becomes harsh and hard and painful and
dark but because of the prophet's concern because of the prophet's love you see even those
who were hurting and harming him the most experiencing that Mercy in a very unique way
in a way that they didn't even know to appreciate that they were not even aware
of the famous incident where he went to T in the latter part of the mechan
period of the S when he was seeking Refuge amongst those in
and ultimately they rejected him and they bloodied him and they bruised him and they beat
him and he entered into a garden right outside of T and he was sitting down
and the angel came down to him and said to him you just give me the
command and I will make it that the two mountains that surround th that they will
destroy this entire area this entire Village of th
the prophet sallallahu alaih wasallam said no no for my hope
is that perhaps I hope that who will be come from their loins will be someone
who is a servant of Allah you can only consider that in the space of a
servant Prophet who imbus and exudes profound mercy and compassion and has a foresight
that does not just look at the simple transactional qualities of this world you know the
push and pull but rather he's thinking about the he's thinking about the afterlife he's thinking
about people's salvation he's thinking about The Offspring who's going to come forth what is going
to be the impact of such a decision why am I am I doing this for
me I would never do this for myself that's what the prophet wasam said he never
became angry when you read his sh he never be became angry for himself everything that
really drove him and motivated and defined his decisions was this servanthood this mercy and compassion
so he was thoughtful he was thoughtful about the outcome I want to see Believers no
no no no it's okay I got blood Eed and bruised I got hurt but I'm
okay I can survive this as long as Allah's not bothered with me then I then
I have no problems I don't want to see those people destroyed the prophet was not
a man of Destruction he was not a man of arrogance and ego and vengefulness he
wasn't self-centered and self-absorbed he didn't behave you know like he was Upon A fom no
he had behaved and embodied this humble beautiful servant
spirit that exuded endless amounts of mercy and
compassion for